تم انتقاد حملة الاجتياح الاستثنائي التي جرت في نهاية هذا الأسبوع
لأعضاء بارزين في العائلة المالكة
والمسؤولين الحكوميين لرجل الأعمال
باعتباره لعبة قوة
لتوطيد السلطة من قبل ولي
العهد الذي قال إن هذه تحقيقات لمكافحة
الفساد سنجريها لمن هم
في القمة.  لا مفر من
ما تقوله لهؤلاء النقاد الذين يرون أن
هذا تطهير فعال لمعارضته
، أقول ، حسناً ، إن المملكة العربية السعودية لديها سياسة صفرية
عندما يتعلق الأمر بدعم
الإرهاب والتطرف ، يبدو أن ريبا
لديها الآن سياسة صفرية عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالفساد و  الهدر وسوء الإدارة
تدعو رؤيتنا 2030 إلى
حكومة شفافة وخاضعة للمساءلة
لا يمكننا تحمل الفساد
والهدر وسوء الإدارة يقلل من
قدرتنا على تحسين حياة
شعبنا ولهذا السبب تم إنشاء الهيئة العليا
لمكافحة الفساد
برئاسة صاحب السمو الملكي
المؤتمر  وهي الآن منخرطة في
القيام بعملها ، لذا فهي تساعد
هناك سببًا لوجود الجميع
تم إحضارهم أو موتهم وسيتم
استجوابهم وسيتم التحقيق معهم
وهذه تتعلق باللجنة
ولكنني متأكد من أنه عندما
تكتمل التحقيقات
سيعرف الناس ما هي الأسباب ولكن أنا
وزير الخارجية نحن  قم
بالسياسة الخارجية ولكن يمكنني أن أؤكد لك أن
مملكة سيرجيفا تأخذ على
محمل الجد قضية هدر الفساد
وسوء الإدارة ، لا نريد
أن يثق المستثمرون في نظامنا ،
نريد أن تعرف الشركات أنه
عندما يأتون للمنافسة في السعودية
شبه الجزيرة العربية يمكنهم التنافس بشكل عادل ومربع
مع أي شركة أخرى وعدم
الخضوع لأشخاص يستخدمون نفوذهم
أو مركزهم من أجل الحصول
على صفقات أفضل